Welcome to A.B. Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Hey everybody, welcome back to another episode of A.B. Testing.
I am Spy and I am here with Global Warming.
Global Warming, say hi.
Yeah, hi.
I'm not Brent.
We're here, not Alan and not Brent.
He glitched a little bit there, but I'm going to assume you said hi and the audio is being
recorded.
You'll come back.
Love the internet.
Coming to us from, I know Germany.
What part of Germany are you in?
Bavaria.
It's like the southern part of Germany, the real southern part, Munich, actually.
But I grew up in the basically most northern part of Germany, so I've been traveling
like step by step to the south.
Are you moving to Austria soon?
Are you going to move yourself out of Germany all the way south?
If I continue on, you mean, yeah, I guess at some point, maybe if like the conditions
here get worse, then I have to move someplace.
Well I can say the same thing, if the conditions here get worse, I'll have to move
someplace.
All right.
Good.
We'll keep things going.
I'm just going to assume you keep talking.
Brent is actually, he got stuck, he's cleaning Satya's floors today and so he couldn't come
to the podcast.
Satya apparently does a lot of pacing in his office and Brent's putting in some
new carpet and all cleaned up and we're figured out.
So he should be back again soon.
Brent hope you're doing well and good luck getting those carpets cleaned.
Global warming or I'll just call you a G, it's not really a W, I'll call you
a global warming.
I'm going to play the part of Brent today and we have part of an agenda somewhere, some
things to talk about.
So we're going to talk about, oh, I don't know, let's talk about, let's talk about
the last podcast and then we'll get into quality.
First of all, by doing the part for Brent, I have to like get some eating going, like
typing.
Right.
You have to eat, you have to play with the cat, the cat has to meow into the
microphone, all those things.
So you don't have to turn on the notifications turning on, right?
And then you have to have your phone notification, then we are ready to talk about quality.
Oh my God.
So this will all tie together.
All these topics will tie together, but I want to talk about, I had a great comment
from one of our three wonderful listeners after the last podcast and I talked about
how I had tracked all of my project metrics for a year and found some good insights.
And I'm a big believer, and this will come up later in the podcast.
I'm a big believer that you need to measure the system.
I think a lot of people measure and don't measure just the system, but I think
what a lot of people measure are the results of the system.
We have test pass results and code coverage and deployment rate.
People get all excited about the Dora metrics.
This drives me crazy.
And again, they're very good metrics.
And those are, you know, I've been out of it for so long.
I forgot what they are.
I don't care.
I do care.
Deployment velocity, mean time to recovery, things like that, which
companies after Accelerate came out.
Wonderful book.
Teams clamored to build dashboards that automatically measured these things.
Yet forgot that what those measurements are, those measurements occur and improve
when the system improves.
Measurements are just like tools for maybe helping you doing the right thing.
Right.
People get stuck.
They want to build an automated dashboard for everything.
And what they forgot is, or what they, and so many people,
man, I've been spending time on LinkedIn and it's full of so many fricking idiots.
And for years, people were like, we're going to measure these metrics.
They've never read the book, the book, and they don't realize those metrics
came from surveys, not from trying to put a dashboard in place to measure
these things and deploying faster doesn't make your software higher quality.
You can, for any of those things you can measure, you can make shortcuts.
So you want to measure the system.
So the thing I talked about with Tim a little bit was I tracked a bunch of
metrics on product delivery and estimates.
And I use that.
We use that to learn continuously and to track improvements and things.
And we got some insights, which is pretty cool.
So go ahead.
You're going to ask a question.
What kind of things did you track then?
Maybe I didn't follow everything.
Okay.
I tracked, so in summary, because I realized not all three listeners
listen to every episode.
One of the things I'll back up a bit.
When I lead teams, I expect I don't have scrum masters.
I think it's a, and I'm sorry if you're a scrum master today,
but it's, I think it's a dying role or unnecessary role.
I believe engineering leads need to own their project management
and they need to learn how to do it because they're going to need
to learn how to do that as they become engineering managers,
engineering directors and engineering VPs and engineering, whatever, after that.
They need to learn how to get their teams to deliver.
I don't care what they use.
I don't care if it's scrum.
By the way, scrum was invented before the Agile Manifesto.
People just wedged it in there to make it work.
And most people use scrum.
Tim and I talked about this.
Most people use scrum to pretend that they're doing Agile
without actually being Agile, which is adaptive, not iterative.
You were mentioning safe as this kind of wrapper around scrum.
Oh, and safe is just horrible.
The vomit is coming up in my mouth as I talk about it.
So what I do is I require, I ask my dev leads to give estimates
on everything they deliver.
When is this project going to be done?
And again, predicting the future is impossible,
but we're trying to give the best guess.
So I had to use confidence levels.
So give me a date that you have a 50% confidence in.
And what I found in years of experimenting is that 50% is a sweet spot
between putting some decent planning into place
and completely guessing on what you're doing.
I go over this stuff weekly with the leads.
And what I track is the day their initial estimate date
and the actual date they deliver.
So I can get deltas between the date something's actually done
and the day they thought it would be done.
And the short story is things that I predicted
to be right around two weeks, from 12 to 16 days,
they were correct 80% of the time.
It's a really good sweet spot for delivery,
which I think why for teams using Scrum,
why two weeks sprint, gross, works really well.
What I found is anything over four weeks
was all over the map, all over the map.
Almost all of them were late.
A few were extremely early
because they thought it was going to be four weeks
and ended up being like three days.
But for the most part,
anything four weeks and beyond impossible to estimate.
And this is across an entire team of about 300 engineers.
Now you're just about measuring
how good they are about estimating.
What is the intended change in behavior?
The goal is I want them to get better at estimating.
Again, I balance transparency.
If they read my newsletters,
transparency, psychological safety, and accountability.
And by being accountable for dates.
And also when they get a date wrong,
we have a weekly meeting to discuss these things.
And they say, gonna need to move the date out
on this project by four days.
And at first I say, great.
What did you learn and why?
And they'll tell me, oh, I forgot to calculate
for an employee being out of the office.
Or we had a dependency on team X
and they're behind because of A, B, and C.
And I can ask,
how could you plan for better for that in the future?
I said, we can have probably a shorter conversation
upfront with that team will work better.
A little bit, just a teeny little 20 second retro
if a date needs to change.
And over time, when I ask that question,
they'll say, our project is moving out five days
because we failed to anticipate this.
And to me to get this in the future,
we're going to do this.
That's the learning I want to see.
So they get better over time because I don't care
if they're wrong.
We're humans, we make mistakes.
What I want them to do is make a mistake,
learn from it, and get better the next time.
And they do.
I wonder if this will be misunderstood.
And as you as last time said,
like now that these stats are out,
it's bound to impact reality.
And people will maybe try to game it
and try to aim for this kind of day range,
which is like maybe a good thing,
but also-
Well, let me talk about that as well then.
Yeah, they would.
And I waited a year to release these metrics.
I said, here's some interesting stats.
And I talked to our CEO about it.
And yeah, they could try and game them.
But here's how I-
Let's talk about transparency side of this.
When I lead teams,
this meeting I talked about is a weekly meeting
with the lead stakes between even going over-
There might be 30 projects across a large team
in progress at once, or maybe even more.
I've had like 50 or 60.
I can get through them all in a 30-minute meeting.
Talking to folks that are on time,
looking where risk is.
But what happens is-
But what happens is,
is transparency.
All the leads are there.
They know enough about how things interact.
They can tell if someone's padding and trying to game.
So let's say John says,
okay, we have this new project.
It's coming in.
It's going to be about four weeks to get done.
Here's the impact it's going to have, blah, blah, blah.
And then because it's transparent
and we have psychological safety
and people can speak up,
when Jane chimes in and says,
I did something very similar to this
and I think it should be really a two-week project.
And I'm not going to have the argument there
that good insight, Sally.
Sorry, Sally.
Jane, my made-up names are getting lost.
Jane, can you and John talk offline,
figure out-
This is like planning poker.
Figure out where we may be able to optimize
or where you may be missing information
and come back next week and give me an update
or send me an update over email or Slack email.
What is this, 1997?
Send me an update over Slack
and let me know what you figure out.
I want teams to challenge each other.
I want teams to hold each other accountable.
It's not being accountable to me.
It's about being accountable to yourself
and being accountable to your teammates.
I'm just a facilitator.
I just make sure they have the right conversations.
It's not like people shouldn't be afraid
to give me a date change,
shouldn't be afraid to give me an estimate
that somebody challenges.
If we get through the whole meeting
and nobody's challenged anything,
that means I have work to do to get the team to open up.
They don't feel safe enough to challenge.
I want that to happen.
I encourage that to happen.
It has to happen for this to work
so you don't get too bad.
You're actually looking for the next team, right?
You're still on the low key.
Oh, yeah.
I'm just talking about things I've done in the past.
I'm not doing this right now.
I'm talking to some cool companies, though.
Even this time of year when hiring's not going on,
I'm keeping myself busy.
We'll talk more about that.
In a minute.
Or more likely, the way we talk, like 30 minutes.
But yeah, looking for a gig, I'm being selective.
But these, if any potential employers are listening,
these are the principles I operate by.
You can tell this from my newsletter.
And yeah, it helps teams deliver.
Because they, I want, anyway, yes,
I'm still looking for a gig.
These are things I've done in the past,
things I will continue to do
because it's the way I operate and I know it works.
Oh, and I was wondering if potential employers
could make themselves advertised to you
by having some kind of pickleball hall.
How do you play pickleball in winter?
Are there halls there or?
This is not German winter.
It rains a lot here in Seattle, but we don't get snow.
I played outside for a couple hours on Wednesday.
It was great.
So we can play outside as long as it's dry,
the court's dry.
There is a place near my house
that has pickleball inside.
Here's the interesting thing about Seattleites.
And again, in my mini retirement,
I'm playing pickleball three, four, five times a week.
And Seattle, if it's not raining,
people will want to be outside
because we miss daylight.
We have gray days and we have dark gray days.
And it doesn't snow much, but it's cold.
So anyway, Wednesday, it's funny.
They had indoor pickleball on Wednesday,
but nobody went inside because it was,
the sun was out a little bit
and the courts were dry.
So we all played outside.
There must have been 15, I can count here,
four, six, eight, 12, probably eight waiting.
So yeah, about 20 people on the court
on a weekday at 10 to noon when I was there
hanging out, playing pickleball, it was fun.
But yeah, but you can do inside
when there's gross weather,
but just two days a week where I live.
And if I wanted to drive somewhere
and I never drive anywhere,
if I wanted to drive somewhere,
I could probably find more pickleball to play.
But it's easy just to walk by.
I kind of walk by on my way back
from the grocery store.
So anyway, so that's the recap of that.
But looping the story back around
and actually connecting stories
as we never do on the A-B testing podcast,
I tracked all these projects for a year,
but I also tracked every single mile
and step I took on the PCT,
which I did for those of you.
Nice segue.
Well, this listener asked
and they asked like, this is great.
Of course you track this stuff.
You should talk about how you tracked
all your miles on the PCT.
So vanity metrics, who cares?
Every move on every day.
Well, what's interesting is
there's nothing really insightful about it.
It's consistent.
I tracked, I thought it would be funny.
Someone actually, someone else asked me
if you should track your number of steps every day.
So every day I tracked,
all I had to do was mark down on a spreadsheet
what mile number I stopped at
and how many steps I took that day
according to my phone, my watch.
My Garmin watch tracked it.
Well, I actually did more on my watch
the last two weeks, but so the phone tracked it.
So it's, you know, as accurate as step counts are.
There's a, but, so it took me.
So the PCT, quick stats here.
PCT is broken into five sections,
the desert, the Sierra, North and California,
Oregon and Washington.
It took me 40 days to get from the desert
to the beginning of the Sierra.
I took four, what's called a zero day in there
or a day I don't do any miles.
I took three days off to hang with some friends
in near Wrightwood and I took one day off
in Tehachapi, so about 700 miles average
for the days I hiked just under 20 miles a day.
Not too much elevation game,
but you'll see as I go through this stuff,
which is only interesting to me,
but you can ask questions is,
you know, average miles in the desert,
19 and a half median, just under 19 and a half.
And my biggest days, I had two 27 mile days.
My longest hiking day in the desert was 27.8 miles.
So I'm warmed up, I'm warmed up.
I've gotten to the mountains.
They're steep, there's snow.
Did I slow down a little?
Took me 22 days to get from Kennedy Meadows
to Sonora Pass or what we call Kennedy Meadows South
and Kennedy Meadows North.
It's funny, there's a Kennedy Meadows South
They're named for two different Kennedys
and they happen to just be on both sides
of the Sierra Range.
PCT is weird.
I took three, did I take three zero days in there?
Where did I zero?
My stats say I took three zero days.
I took one in, oh no,
I don't remember where I took them off.
Look at my sheet.
I should remember.
I know I took one in Lake Tahoe.
Where were the other two?
Oh, you know what?
I took two zero, a zero and a half in Kennedy Meadows.
I counted as zero days.
That section's not that long.
Average 17 miles a day.
But did do, it's a lot of snow,
a lot of water crossing, a lot of up and down.
Did get a 25 mile day in there.
No big deal.
Pack was heavier too.
Northern California, also known as hell,
which is from Kennedy Meadows North
up to the Oregon border.
As I mentioned before, it's dry and desert
and ash and climbing over trees all the time
because the trail's not that one that will maintain.
35 days, two zeros, one in Shasta.
Small interruption.
At which day did you get your name?
Oh, I don't know which day in the desert.
And we're going to come back to this.
So in the desert, I think I don't know
if I've told this story.
So I kept a trail journal and I blogged
a little bit from my trail journal
on a site called The Trek.
And somewhere in my newsletter,
you can find a link to that, thetrek.co.
I met this really cool couple from Pennsylvania.
Their names were Spout and Yeti.
And I won't go to how they got their names,
but as you don't know me in person, I'm quiet.
You know, I'm observant.
I pay attention to things.
I find patterns.
So I do those things,
but also I was keeping this trail journal
and I was talking into my phone.
And one day Spout came running up behind me
and said, are you a spy?
You're just always watching things
and talking into your phone.
I said, maybe.
She goes, well, what's your trail name?
Spy.
So I became a spy and it stuck.
And I liked it because I could,
if I came out of the woods somewhere,
or whether I'm getting lost
or off doing trail duties or whatever,
people go, oh my God, where'd you come from?
I said, I was doing spy stuff.
Cannot tell you.
Yeah.
So spy kind of stuck.
And I even have, I don't have it here.
I have, I even got a new hoodie
that says spy on the back.
I don't have it here,
but lots of spy stuff.
That's great for podcasting.
Yeah.
Spy has become a persona and I like being spy.
When I hear my government name used,
it just sounds weird still,
even after being back from the trail
for a month, a month and a half,
two months and a half, something like that.
Anyway, yeah, somewhere back there.
There Cal, I mentioned gross.
Average is 20, median 22, max day 28.
Yeah, big.
We joked that the C in PCT stood for California
because California looks forever.
Finally get to Oregon.
Oregon, Haldas, 22 days to get across Oregon.
Averaging 21, just over 21 miles a day,
median 22.3, max day,
my biggest day on trail, 33 miles.
I was hiking and that 33 mile day was,
we should get to this water source
and camp there and get to the water source.
There's already 12 tents there.
We wedge in next to this poor hiker
in a hammock who was going southbound
and we just got these slanted spots
next to him, crashed there,
woke up the next morning, decided,
eh, we can make it to the next water source.
Didn't even go get the water
because it's like a half mile off trail.
So that was why I did 33 miles that day.
But Oregon's also the day where I messed up my ankle
and so I had a couple of 15 mile days.
So the fact that I had two 15 mile days
because I hiked with a smashed ankle
and still averaged over 21
is pretty good miles there.
You're going to say something.
I was just, yeah, feeling with you.
I'm first emphasizing,
emphasizing this year with you with the ankle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then Washington hauled,
but again, 20 miles a day,
a little slower Washington's a lot of up and down.
Hiked a couple of days.
My son came out.
We affectionately called him Spy Kid
and he hiked a couple of days.
He hiked from Soqualmi Pass
to Stevens Pass about 70 miles, 75 miles with us.
But still 21 miles a day,
30 mile day at the max,
one zero in Washington at Soqualmi Pass.
But yeah, so a couple of interesting thoughts
that move on because I track this stuff.
I look for look at patterns,
look for insights, track the system.
Oregon, of course, the fastest,
probably endurance wise Washington
because just took the one zero over
because you're in shape.
By then you want to finish.
And I said before on here,
your legs and feet are completely done,
but your brain is not.
So you just kind of push through and get it done.
But mileage increased
after this year pretty well,
a little slower in Washington.
It looks as I looked at other people's stats.
It better publish them pretty much the same as online.
My lowest non-zero day was where?
Oh, I think it was coming out of Stahican.
There's like a took a did not take it.
Wanted to take a zero in Stahican.
Stahican is probably the last town before the past.
You get to one place where you can hitch in the town
actually with a hike finishes at hearts pass.
But I think it is probably the shortest day there,
non-zero day, but only to like five or six miles
from camp to from the trailhead to the camp.
So yeah, so probably more.
I wanted to find something really interesting
in there around.
Tried to find some insights of like,
okay, after a zero day, I did this many miles.
I did more miles, but not really.
I was rested, but also getting back on the trail
after a town day is difficult because you're relaxed.
You've eaten a whole bunch of food.
Your pack is super heavy.
So the rest doesn't make you go farther the next day.
Just kind of makes the whole thing more sustainable.
You got to wind up again, right?
You're slowing down and you're taking a breath
and then you get some of that wind up.
Yeah, and some of my hardest days on.
Yeah, exactly.
Some of my hardest days on trail were days
after I had taken a couple zeros in a row
or even one zero.
It was hard to get back into especially
at first into the mindset.
It's funny.
I was in the California desert a few weeks ago
near where the PCT is.
It seems so long ago and so different
because I think I was a different person,
definitely different hiker in the desert
than I was when I finished.
So just it's yeah, the stats are fun to revisit
and no totally exciting insights
other than the fact that I finished
and walked however gazillion miles.
But yeah, just interesting.
So any thoughts on that?
But of course I track everything.
So I have lots of metrics and oh,
how many steps is it from you think
according to my Apple phone
and my Garmin watch working together
from the Mexican border to the Canadian border?
The trail is 2655 miles.
I did take a side trip to Mount Whitney
and Mount San Jacinto and Mount Baden Powell
and probably a few other
and I took a couple treks off trail
to get to towns
where I had to hike off trail for a while.
How many steps?
I'm so ignorant when it comes to geography
and you're using freedom numbers
and I can't do mental calculations
with freedom numbers.
So somebody else has to take somebody
and select like write your guesses
and choose like the closest gets.
Actually, let's get back to that.
I'm going to convert for here
because I recognize your pain.
I think it's like 6,000 or 5,000 kilometers.
But let me do the math here.
Yeah, I'm way off.
It is 4,273 kilometers.
4,200 and I guess like I take a step at like a meter.
So 4,000, 4 million, 5 million steps.
Yeah, I'm five foot eight.
So my steps are a little bit shorter.
7.2 million.
And let's double that.
Just double that because like
I don't know if you take upward steps,
smaller steps or more steps when you go upwards.
They're all small.
I'm not a fast hiker.
So yeah, it's 7.2 million steps was the total
and I could probably break it down.
I could probably do some cool analysis
and see if my steps per mile changed at all.
But it didn't.
I looked at it.
When Brent's back, I'll give him my stats
until he'll be able to find stuff.
He's a data scientist.
He can find some cool insights,
but mostly I just walked and it was fun.
So that I'm going to segue again here.
So there's my hike stats.
You can go to our Slack group at oneofthethree.slack.com.
I need to update the link.
Someone emailed me this week
and told me my link was dead
and it was because I forgot to renew it.
So I had to go update the web page, but I forgot.
And so far, so I'll get to it.
Slack group.
You can ask questions about the hike.
It's all the stats I have.
They're interesting and also not interesting
because there's nothing remarkable in there
other than I walked a whole bunch of miles.
But you can also ask Spy
about general management quality,
people leadership things and the blog posts
and the newsletter, I think,
was what you wanted to talk about it, right?
Yeah, I got nothing to do.
I got nothing to do.
So I've been writing.
I'll talk a little bit more about writing in a second.
But one of the things I wrote recently,
and I think you had some tangential comments
or tangential ideas to this,
is my latest newsletter
is about quality being a system.
And this goes back to you measure
the results of the system, not the things.
What Brent and I have talked about a lot
is teams are so ultra focused on testing
that they don't measure quality.
And I don't really care about testing.
It needs to happen, but I care about quality.
And one of the things I called out this blog post,
actually the main thing I called out
is quality is a result of the system.
If you build a quality system,
odds are you're going to build a quality product.
Had a little pushback on that in the comments.
Someone said systems don't have quality.
Only things have quality.
And I disagree.
I mean, yes, things have quality.
But you don't generally produce a quality thing
from a bad system.
And a bad system can produce a quality thing,
but not consistently.
So, and I will stand by that.
And it's not like,
and I was accused of redefining quality,
but I just used piercings
from Zen and the Art of Motorcycle Maintenance's
explanation of quality,
which is a philosophy of quality,
but not maybe not quality in the way
traditional testers view quality.
So, I'm curious.
Yeah, well, I guess, I guess.
Yeah, go ahead.
Traditional testers,
I would say good testers do care
about the way of thinking about quality
in terms of attention and care, right?
That's one of the main points,
taking care and attention to things.
And that's totally in the testers' wheelhouse, right?
But it is.
But I, a lot of,
and I'm curious in your take on this is
I think a lot of testers,
and again, my view is not talking to folks like you.
We have a nice little almost echo chamber
on the modern testing slack,
people who get that quality as a system
and they get that we have to build quality in
as a result of behaviors and practices,
not heroics.
But when I go to LinkedIn to look at jobs,
I see posts from people talking about
just the dumbest things about how testers work.
And it's just, it's so 1999 to me.
So you had something, I forget, I've already forgotten.
I should have it here in front of me.
But let me ask you a question
if I can find my notes here.
Tell me about your thoughts on
regarding bad quality and bad luck.
Hey, it's kind of related to your newsletter, really.
I thought so.
That's why I brought it up here.
It's been recently, I think, maybe,
yeah, maybe AI has played a role.
Let me start differently.
Do you know persons who run into trouble
more often than others, seemingly?
Like I have people in my vicinity who have,
they always come up with stories.
Like I was trying to book like a flight
and I got like this trouble.
I had like customer support issues
and always like some folks who are always finding
and dealing with issues in their life.
We used to call them bug magnets.
And I was wondering like if bug magnets are just,
I don't know, yeah, okay, bug magnets.
I seem to observe bug magnets.
If they really exist, I don't know,
but I observe bug magnets.
People seem to...
I have thoughts.
I think it could be partially true.
I think it comes from a couple different things
and they're actually at odds with each other.
Some people just notice things more closely.
Like, oh, this is off.
I'm gonna make, or this seems wrong.
And they're not necessarily a magnet.
They're good observers.
And some people, the magnets get,
there are these folks on LinkedIn that drive me nuts.
They're kind of magnets
because they're great noticers of things,
but they also notice very trivial mundane things
that don't matter to 99.9% of the users.
But they dwell on them and talk about,
and then they eventually, this is what drives me crazy.
They eventually evolve into blaming poor testing
or poor management or AI or automation
or whatever for the fact that these things
they noticed are broken.
I'm not gonna call people out
and I don't follow this person,
but I follow enough people that add comments
to their posts that they show up on my feed,
but they're constantly talking about the bugs they found
and how software is horrible.
And there are things that just don't matter.
So the bug magnets notice these things.
There's another end of things.
And I'll tell a story about this
from when I was at Microsoft.
On Windows 98 and beyond,
the consumer version of Windows,
I did a lot of app compatibility work,
trying to figure out why apps weren't working.
I worked on the three core components of Windows
at the time, the graphical designer interface,
user interface, GDI, user, and kernel,
which were, and kernel was actually,
I won't go into the details.
This is how the app,
this is the main libraries applications were built on.
I'll just say that.
And there would be a tester.
And I say, hey, this,
it looks like this application shouldn't work
because we had lots of data on stuff
and how they called APIs.
Can you show me how you've been testing this?
Make sure we can figure out what's going on.
And they'd walk through and they would,
like this obvious error would come up
and they click dismiss and keep going.
I said, hold on, wait a minute.
What's going on?
They said, I said, what do you mean?
I'm trying to show you how I test this.
But there was that error and you just skipped over it.
That comes up all the time.
So I don't worry about it.
I said, no, you need to tell me.
And there are a class of folks
who notice these things barely,
but are able to work around them so easily.
And they're not all so obvious,
but they're able to work around these errors
in a way that makes it seem to their subconscious
at least doesn't exist.
So I think a lot of folks kind of live in between.
I mean, all software has bugs, all software.
And if you don't agree, yeah, all software has bugs.
I think the majority of people,
and again, also whether it's a bug,
whether it's an actual bug or something is broken
or it's just not intuitive or anything in between,
it all exists.
Some people are really good
at subconsciously working around the non-intuitiveness.
You can look at, I mean, Photoshop,
super powerful software, super difficult to use.
Is it buggy?
Well, a little bit, but is it useful?
Hell yes.
And people have learned to work around those things so well
that it's provided them value,
which according to Weinberg is quality.
I think some folks get so caught up
in every single thing not working
that they are a bug magnet,
but they're a bug noticer more than a bug magnet.
And they get stuck.
It's like when someone who's neurodivergent
sees something wrong
and they just can't stop thinking about it
to the fact they can't move on with their work.
I think some testers are like that
and said some companies for some project is very valuable.
I don't know if most users operate like that.
When I look at the software I use,
I had a team's call this week for a job interview.
Teams is a horrible piece of software
and I can say that having worked on it.
But I can make it work.
I know how to work around it.
I don't sit there and talk about how awful it is
other than this podcast
because it works more or less for what I need it to do.
Is it intuitive?
No.
Is it bug free?
Is it seamless?
No.
Is it easy to use?
But I can make it work.
I'm not going to go post on LinkedIn
about how this and this and this
don't make sense for the user
and this and this and this
because the work around is so easy
that I can use it even though it sucks.
And I think probably most people
live in that area.
Maybe it's been conditioned by decades of bad software
but I think people just tend to work around these things
which is not great for testers.
You do want testers who notice those things
but, and I'll tie this into a future subject
after I let you talk for a second
but I think testers, too many testers
and too many testers who people follow
get stuck in the fact that bugs exist
and lose fact that not all bugs are created equal
and only a subset of those actually impact
customer usage, customer acquisition
customer attention, etc.
I could kind of turn around and say maybe
I don't know if the software is getting worse
if that's like old man yelling at cloud things
or like software getting worse
I don't know with AI maybe
the error margins are getting bigger
I don't but you are not like the 99
like I wonder if you're producing so much bad software
that this kind of edge cases and flakiness
and bad bad experiences accumulate for some folks
especially for the folks who are looking
looking for these things and taking care and notice
and I think calling onto your newsletter
it's they rightfully say that people should
maybe take more care and attention overall
because yeah we're producing
getting better at producing more and more code
and more and more software
and for more and more people
but like the I don't know
somebody might roll a natural one on there
like technology use or whatever
and just happen to be in these overlapping
cumulating zones of bad experience
and then it's like three years of a life gone
because the heart rate is always like at the top
because they're just yeah
But what's missing and this is the
one of the most ironic things I find around testing
and the modern testing principles
which are dismissed by these same people
is the tester is not the customer
and the tester can try and represent
the customer that's fine
but the fact that I as a as a tester
or someone testing software
notices something wrong
and fail to map that to what customers are doing
and how they're actually using the product
is I find it extremely ironic
and the fact that they push back on that principle
that says that only customers can evaluate quality
ultimately that's absolutely true
there's it and we talked about this
I think when you were on last time
this is the Weinberg definition of quality
that these folks adopt
is it's value to some person
and they added who matters
which I find you know it just irony over irony
it doesn't matter if a tester finds a bug
I mean I get the phrase that differently
before I get yelled at
if someone finds a bug it may matter
and if you fail to map that potential issue
and some bugs just going to fix as a matter of what
but but the you want to find the bugs
where the customers use the product
actually yeah that's it
when I look at these
when they look at these testing demos
some of these people do
they get caught up in finding very esoteric
interesting bugs and they're fun
the fact that I can
there was one like 10 years ago
or if you put this sequence
and you save it as a file
it comes up as Chinese and notepad
because you could make the language detection fail
it's like that's really cool
who cares
it's not it's any text of any length
it's going to get fixed anyway
it's just a it's a really cool bug
and I love really cool bugs
but do customers
any customer ever get impacted by that
no they did not
absolutely 1 million percent did not
so I just get where was I going
oh principle five customers
look at how the customer is using the project product
if it's so funny it's a principle
it's just the principle
like principle five principle five
it's useless on its own
like the like the sentence quality is
value to some person at some time
it's also on its own worthless
you have to ask about okay
what kind of customer
what kind of value what time
how many customers do we actually have
where are they when are they
and etc etc right
yeah and that's it exactly
so I want I want people to see things
so I have
when did I get back from the trail
I'm going to segue this into something else
we can talk about here
a little little preview of something I'm working on
I got home on September 15th
October November
it's almost it's coming up on three months
since I've been home
I spent the first month transitioning
I it was weird being back
I mentioned before it's weird going from
everything fitting into a backpack
to having things everywhere
I've purged some things
I'm going to purge some more
I purge almost every day
I spent a month
I did some I've done some traveling
I've been applying for jobs
I've had some
at least first rounds of interviews
and some really really cool companies
none of them have been a good fit
from my side really
again I'm looking for companies care
about good software
care about people
and then also a large enough scope
and again not number of people
but a large enough ownership of engineering
I can affect the culture
I really you know my
as long time listeners know
I believe in creating a culture
people can do their best work
because I believe all the data
and statistics that tell me that teams
that are healthy organizations
produce higher quality software
more predictable software etc
and that's what I do
but I've had some time to kill
I've written some newsletters
and I forget who it was in our slack group
that called out that
hey the newsletters are still me
but they're different
because I took a lot of time
to think while I was hiking
and I have so many drafts ready
I will keep hiking them
this last post on quality of the system
is actually came from
another project I've been working on
I'm going to share for our listeners here
because we have just enough time
to give a few little previews
and then talk about it
something I maybe mentioned a year ago
in fact last November
during NaNoWriMo
you've heard of this
National November Writers Month
is November
in the US at least
I don't know if it's global
and the idea was
people would try and write
a novel in November
I started a year ago
got part way through
got distracted
couldn't do it
it was too hard
I did not plan on this November being
I didn't like sign up for the website
we can get accountability and things
but I was back from the hike
so back in
I guess starting in November
maybe a little earlier
something I've wanted to do
for a long time
was write a narrative fiction
or a business fable
a story about modern testing
I think what gets lost in the principles
is people
they take them out of context
they can't figure it out
they get hurt by them
principle number five especially
and what I wanted to do
was write a story
in the style of any of the
Patrick Lancioni novels
or the Phoenix Project
Unicorn Project
The Goal
what's Christina Wodke's book called
Radical Focus
Story is the tallest story
and by the way
Tangent
that's what we talk about
Christina Wodke wrote this book
called Radical Focus
which is the best book
well the best companion book ever
on OKRs
probably the
what's the Intel guys one
there are more
non-fictiony approaches
which are really good
again OKRs
like modern testing principles
when people don't know enough
about them
they do them wrong
they abuse them
they don't work
and they go oh my god
these are stupid
because what they're doing
aren't OKRs
Christina Wodke's book
great story about
introducing OKRs
in a way that people
don't feel like
they're doing some sort of
bureaucracy thing
so what I wanted to do
I was inspired by those
I love the business fables
I've read like all Lancioni's books
I've read them all
what I wanted to do
was attempt to write a story
about a team
now I'm going to read
a few excerpts of it
it's just about done
I have some editing to do
I'm actually going to start working on
finding a publisher
or an agent
beginning next week for this
because it's done enough
what I wanted to write about
was a team
that is struggling to release
and I'm going to read
some of the beginning for you
then I'll read some
a little bit from the middle-ish
but they struggle
a consultant comes in
it's not clear he's a consultant
but the VP of engineering
brings in someone
to work with their leader of testing
and it's about discovery
and systems
and figuring out
how to basically
implement the principles
without implementing the principles
I don't mention the principles
till about three quarters
the way through the book
but let me
and let me just start from
let me just read
like I'm going to read
if you don't mind
can I read like
three chapters from this book
they're short chapters
there's 90 chapters in the book
go ahead let's see your podcast
I'm just a guest here
you can do whatever you want
all right no okay
well I'm going to juggle
because that's a great podcasting thing
all right and again
editing to go isn't perfect yet
but I'll read a chapter
and get your feedback
do another one from the middle
and then one from the end
I think I don't have plans here
I'm faking it as I go
Anna Patel stopped
just inside the release room door
and held her breath
the way people do
when they're preparing for bad news
six monitors lined the wall
each one full of dashboards
no one trusted
the QA team sat shoulder to shoulder
at a long table
scrolling through spreadsheets
with a steady focus of people
searching for something fragile
and hard to find
a few developers
hovered near the back
pretending to check slack
while staying close enough
to hear the verdict
Anna took one step further
into the room
and felt the familiar shift in the air
there was a tightness here
that came from too many release days
shaped by uncertainty
it wasn't fear exactly
more like a collective readiness
for the next bad surprise
on monitor three
a row of tests
flickered from yellow to red
a ripple went through the room
not a sound
not a gasp
just a small shared
straightening of posture
people leaned closer to screens
someone stopped typing mid-word
Anna felt the old weight
settle between her ribs
she knew this pattern by heart
failure
confusion
speculation
and eventually blame
TGC had practiced it enough time
to turn it into a muscle memory
no one said anything
they never did
at Trailhead Gear Company
or TGC to the people who work there
silence always arrived first
panic became second
blame showed up right on time
Anna set her notebook on the table
and waited for the ritual to begin
she didn't know when release days
that started to feel like rituals
or when she had started measuring
her work in cycles of relief and dread
somewhere along the way
the team has stopped aiming for confidence
they aimed for luck
and most days luck didn't return their calls
behind her
a developer shifted their weight
the movement soft but anxious
Anna glanced at the monitors again
red
more red
she let out a slow breath through her nose
what they needed was a system
that delivered confidence instead of surprises
what they had was a set of dashboards
that told them only how late the news
bad news had arrived
Anna straightened the papers in front of her
though they didn't need straightening
it was a small grounding motion
she always used right before things unraveled
here we go again she thought
and waited for the day to collapse
the way all the others had
tell me you haven't lived that
tell me you didn't live that way
back in like 2000
how I don't know you're young
but you know
I'm trying to describe in here
like this from what I read
from the non-modern testing crowd
this is their normal
maybe a little maybe a little dramatized
but maybe not
I cannot talk from experience
I've not yet been in these kind of big companies
where these kind of
oh I got all of old-fashioned
I guess teams exist
and these kind of war rooms
and release dreads
I've been lucky
but I do see like the parallels
to other business novels
I have been reading
so yeah I do enjoy the
the narrative drama
I cannot talk to like the accuracy
it's still a story right
some people have experienced them
some people not
but I guess most many people
have experienced these kind of things
from what I've seen on business novel sites
okay I read part of one in the middle
because it's important to set up the last part
because and if you're paying attention to the podcast
you'll see the parallel here
the next morning Anna and Jordan
so Jordan's a consultant
Jordan comes in
Anna didn't hire Jordan
her boss Derek did
Jordan comes up
it's like you know what the hell
and but Jordan's all right
Jordan's probably the coolest guy you'll ever meet
the vice men
the next morning Anna and Jordan
met in a small conference room
this is like several chapters in
as Anna sat down
she noticed a sticker on the back of Jordan's laptop
a small boot print over a desert ridge
you hiked she asked
Jordan smiled
PCT
I finished it last summer before joining TGC
Anna looked up from her notebook
the whole trail
yeah they said
I went northbound
took a little over four months
Anna sat back
that's impressive
Jordan shrugged lightly
you learn a lot when you walk that far
mostly about yourself
and about systems
trails are systems too
just outdoors
she nodded intrigued
did you have a trail name?
Jordan hesitated for a moment
and then smiled
spy
spy Anna repeated
I'm observant they said
quiet always taking notes
someone in the desert said
I pay attention
notice things and find patterns
the name stuck
Anna considered that
should I call you spy?
most people do they said
eventually
Anna gave a small smile
spy it is
and so we'll go on a little bit there
I'm gonna fix one edit here while I'm here
and then so that's
they're short chapters
it's about a 40,000 page book
40,000 page oh my god
40,000 word book right now
that's chapter 27
so Jordan comes in
in chapter 3
27 they finally have that conversation
and then chapter 66 out of 91
so we are three quarters
way through the book
two-thirds of the way through the book
they've been fixing things
continuous improvement
finding and a lot of work
on finding the bottleneck
so borrowed a lot from the goal
because you want it
and finding customer patterns
figuring out
they're figuring out things
along the way like
we're testing the wrong thing
because customers are using
a different path to get here
because they had the data
to figure it out
and they start focusing on
where customers are feeling pain
rather than
where they want to
they feel like testing
so which makes complete sense right
if you if you know
where customers are having pain
go look at that first
our priority is improving the business
our priority is not
increasing code coverage
our priority is not finding information
our priority is improving the business
oh I'll do this first
then I'll go back and do one more
and then we'll wrap here
I think you have
do you have a hard stop
at the top of the hour
okay I'm gonna do this one
okay I'm gonna go in
they flip to a page as a spy
covered in clean handwriting
and simple bullet points
what we're about to talk about
isn't a process or a checklist
they said
it's a set of principles built
from years of seeing teams
succeed and fail
they described how modern teams
deliver software
when both speed and quality matter
these principles explain
where quality actually lives
spy continued
not only in tests
but in how entire systems work
Anna fold her hands go on
spy nodded and began
our priority is improving the business
not perfecting the test suite
spy said
not chasing every risk
we focus where the business needs us most
everything flows from that
we use models like lean thinking
and theory of constraints
to identify prioritize
and mitigate the bottlenecks
in our system
when we improve flow
spy said
quality improves with it
bottlenecks tell us
where our efforts matter the most
tie knotted slowly
that matches everything
we saw this week
we are a force for continuous improvement
we adapt as the system evolves
spy said
we optimize our practices
we don't rely on safety nets
to catch failures after the fact
we prevent problems
by improving the system itself
Anna felt something in her chest
soften recognition
we care deeply about
the quality culture of the team
we coach lead
and nurture the team
towards a more mature quality culture
spy said
testers influence the culture
so that quality becomes
a shared responsibility
not the final checkpoint
Aisha murmured
so we lead by shaping
how the whole team works
exactly spy said
we believe the customer
is the only one capable
of judging and evaluating
the quality of our product
alarm bells don't
this doesn't mean
the customer tests for us
spy said
it doesn't mean anyone
inside the company
speaks for the customer
every signal we rely on
whether it's a test
a dashboard or a checklist
is still an internal guess
the customer shows us the truth
through how they use the product
our job is to learn
from that truth
as early and as safely as we can
Anna paused her writing
to absorb that one
we use data extensively
to deeply understand customer usage
and close the gap
between our product hypothesis
and real business impact
that's how we know what matters
spy said
data tells us
where assumptions
don't match reality
pre-attaptor pen
this will help us focus testing
it will
spy said
we expand abilities
and knowledge across the team
understanding that as we do this
the need for dedicated
specialists may decrease
as skills spread
spy said
teams become stronger
silos weaken
everyone shares responsibility
for outcomes
Ty closed his laptop
that explains the direction
we're heading
comprehensive
not isolated
spy nodded
these principles aren't rules
to follow blindly
they guide how we make decisions
and how we build systems
that work without heroics
thoughts?
yeah i guess the
the self-insert is like a choice
the hard hard self-insert
via name is a choice
i've not seen other authors make
i think
but you use you
who am i
it's just i'm just one of the three
like who cares
the other thing is like
i do
i do it's in tradition
and i do like
putting principles
into stories
to illustrate them
and that makes sense
and it's like
in actual like
a book can have a better
conversation
like you just
you just don't put like this
principles on the table
and that's it
book is a conversation
and like a context
book offers context
it's the context
i wanted to
the explanation comes later
a lot of these have already been
in practice
and shown at this point
but i wanted to show
was that they're not
what i also like is like
in as i never like
these kind of projects always like
it's like years
work of writing a good book
right it's it's a big big
big pile of work
but it's actually
when you think about
culture and systems
et cetera
it's and sometimes
a good way to influence culture
like on a on a whole different level
like not only
in one organization
yeah that's what i'm hoping
and there's a lot more work to do here
i want to read
i put one slight dig in here
that i'm going to share here
it is happens earlier
this is in chapter 2031
it's not a dig
it's a clarification
and you'll find out
what i'm talking about in a second
maybe we're getting
a little low on time here
but maybe this is something
we can merge into the next podcast
but something i wanted to call out
because something that's bugged me
for a long time
and i don't have the effort
to have the discussion online
and the internet
so i'm going to put it in a book instead
the room settled in a way
it hadn't in a long time
it wasn't a celebration
it wasn't skepticism
it was something steadier
willingness
spy looked around the table
one more thing they said
what we're building here
these are tests
not checks
not safety nets
a test tells us something meaningful
about how the system behaves
a check just repeats a rule
and hopes nothing has changed
the team listened closely
spy continued
we're not trying to catch mistakes
we're trying to understand
how the product really works
tests give us information
good information helps us decide
what to do next
that's the work
checks also give information
but the quality is different
i think it's stupid
but i felt it fit
because i think there is a difference
and i think words have meaning
and the meaning works
and the same stuff happens
like you put two words on the table
and then people argue about it
but in the end
i think when you have a conversation
about it
these terms make sense
if you have the same definition
of the terms
i agree
so anyway that's a little preview
for listeners
that's something i've been working on
during my time off
so i've been keeping myself busy
again between pickleball
and the gym
and grocery shopping
and dog walks
i've been doing a little writing
and let me know if you need voice actors
for your for your book right
for the audiobook
yeah i get i'll get the audiobook going
but yeah
i just wanted to share that on here
because it's
i'll probably write a few blog posts
about you know pure
my normal pure fiction
i'm sorry non-fiction
around the concepts in the book
but i think it's time
well one i've always wanted
to write a business novel
but it's also for these principles
they make sense
but i also get why people
look at them in isolation
and go these don't make sense
so i wanted to try
and bridge that gap
hopefully as i get it done
and whether it's a published
or something i share as a pdf
at some point
something that people can use
to understand that
modern testing isn't a leap
in a different direction
it's an evolution
in how you deliver software
and how you build quality
into the system
versus use a team of folks
doing a specific task
to try and build in quality that way
all right well i feel like
i monologued through most of this
but but thanks for being here
because i couldn't do the podcast
on my own
any any any additional thoughts
closing comments
other things you want to mention
here before i close out for today
i have so much things to on on my
on my list
but i have the goal was to come here
and let you talk about
the topics that you're on
and as long as i just replaced
i did that i guess
yeah it did well
so and as long as brent is away
i'm happy to come back
and be here and help you
get your thoughts out again
i'm taking applications for guests
until brent finishes up
asatya's office
i think he's putting in the
he's putting in some wood paddling
and wainscotting next two weeks
that's going to be awesome
but i hope hopefully i'll get pictures
at the end but yeah
if you want to be on the podcast
happy to have you on
but i really appreciate
having you here today
and listening to my rambling
and letting me soapbox
it's fun
it's exciting
it keeps me going
happy to be here
all right well
all right well thanks everyone
for listening to another episode
of the av testing podcast
i am spy
you are not ellen
i am not brent
that works
see you next time
bye
see you